um well Mary we've talked about your
music in the past which I obviously are
on the right show for that um so you
wrote a song for this movie
um that everybody sings at the end right
yeah it was my love song to them it's I
truly love them and so in trying to
write a song I just thought it's got to
be a love song to them and it's called
anywhere with you and I wrote it with
Caitlyn Smith and Troy Burgess who you
know of from Nashville yeah and uh
before we we didn't have time to get you
to sing it so we sang it the more of us
sing it to each other I think that's
cooler that you all did it like yeah
that's the coolest thing ever how did
y'all feel about singing it it was
wonderful yeah we love the song I love
you you're like I rocked it
[Laughter]
um so
so did you know that
I knew that she was yeah musically
inclined and did things like yeah excuse
me but this is Beautiful the song
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going home